[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOSH GORDON: Hey, everyone.
My name is Josh Gordon.
I'm here for "The Developer
Show" with Sherol and Doug.
So Sherol, could you tell me
a little bit about the Magenta
Project and your
role on the team?
SHEROL CHEN: Yeah, so the
Magenta project is really
focused on how
machine learning has
a role in art and expressivity,
and how it can extend
the human creative process.
So that starts with
generative models research,
but then goes into
creating tools
that developers can use
to create these entry
points into using these
models for art and creativity.
JOSH GORDON: So
one of the things
that I think the Magenta project
has done an extraordinarily
good job of is making
reproduceable software
and demos that other
developers can try.
So could you tell me about a
couple of your favorite demos
that you've released
over the past few years?
DOUGLAS ECK: Yeah, we've
done a lot of demos.
I think the goal
of these demos has
been to engage the
developer community
and to bring artists, and
musicians, and creative coders
to work together with us
on these machine learning
problems.
I particularly like
a project that Sherol
talked about today,
Performance RNN, which
learns how to generate
something that's
half a composition and
half a performance,
because all of the
nuanced velocities
and dynamics of a piano
performance are there.
And I really love
the new Music VAE
stuff that's coming
out, where we're
able to explore an
embedding space,
and some really cool
JavaScript-based tools
developed around
TensorFlow.js that
turned things on for everybody.
And I particularly love the idea
that we have other developers
that are not Googlers taking
our JavaScript interface
and playing with
things themselves.
JOSH GORDON: So I actually have
one question for you, Doug.
So you talk a lot about
generative models for Magenta
in the context of art and music.
What do you think
the future might
hold for generative models?
DOUGLAS ECK: I'm
perhaps biased because I
work on this every day.
But what I see is
that the overall field
of generative models is
going to sweep through
in the next decade and become
a major, major part of machine
learning research.
I think all you have to do
is look at what we have with
Translate, end-to-end,
sequence-to-sequence-based
translation, and think, OK, we
can start to get some beautiful
nuanced translations when we
pass between, for example,
English and Japanese.
What can we do if we start
to generate from these models
and try to train these
models to help us write,
help us do visual art, help us
communicate in different ways?
Think of Smart Reply.
You get that one
relevant response.
Now imagine Smart
Reply, but its helping
you craft whole paragraphs.
It's still your message.
It's still you communicating.
But you're seeing
machine learning
help you solve that problem.
I think the future is very, very
bright for generative models.
And very excited
to be part of it.
JOSH GORDON: Sherol,
another thing
that I really, really
like about Magenta
is how easy it is to use the
demos that you've released.
Can you tell me a little bit
about your Docker images,
and the notebooks, and
the different demos
that are available on the
website for developers to try?
SHEROL CHEN: For developers,
of course, its all in GitHub,
open source.
And you can contribute
to the projects as well.
But there's also CoLabs.
And I think CoLabs recently
released just an amazing entry
point into training and
running Magenta models.
And outside of that, we have
just the demos that get built
out of it, anyone can use.
So developers, artists-- you
could have no programming
experience and be
able to still explore
these generative spaces.
DOUGLAS ECK: You know,
Sherol, I'd add to this
that the fact that a
JavaScript developer was
able to play around
with some of our tools
has led us to go full in
on developing Magenta.js
that's heavily integrated
with TensorFlow.js
and also is able
to pull in from P5
and other commonly used
tools for visualization.
And I love the idea that
working with our developers,
even creative coders-- someone
who doesn't think of themselves
as a developer, but
they like to hack--
I want to see people
continue to take our ideas
and twist them around a
little bit, make something
that we didn't quite expect.
And I think we're
getting much closer as we
get simpler and simpler tools
and ways to use our research
in the open source community.
JOSH GORDON: And
one last question.
Where is the best
place for developers
to go to learn more about
Magenta and get started?
SHEROL CHEN: All right.
This is where you go.
You go to G.co/Magenta.
And you'll find
everything there--
blog posts, references
to publications.
The demos themselves
will be linked there.
And finally, last but not least,
the Magenta discussion group,
where we want to
really cultivate
open community for people
to share things they do.
Whether they're
using Magenta or not,
we want to really tap
into the creative space
because we know creativity
is an important part
of the human existence.
And we want to see
more of that and how
technology can promote that.
JOSH GORDON: That's a
great answer, Sherol.
And I like the
DevRel enthusiasm.
So again, Doug and Sherol,
thank you very much.
I'm Josh Gordon for
"The Developer Show."
This has been great.
Thanks very much for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]